and Atlantis or not whether it ever  existed or whether or not the original  structure would be the long lost  location if nothing else like I said  earlier the rear shot structure should  be listed on natural wonders of the  world and not only that the very nature  of the Sahara Desert having clear  evidence that the ocean blasted over it  far more recently than 56 to 66 million  years ago should be a topic that is  front and center among researchers  scientists climate scientists and  everybody geologists this is significant  so I know some people dismiss the  possibility of Atlantis and ridicule the  wrist shot Theory great but like we need  to talk about the science aspect of this  and what the heck happened to the Sahara  Desert